il se positionne forcément hyper
facilement vous ouvrez vous le mettez
vous lâcher il se pose juste là alors
dans l'idée moi je trouve pas ça trop
intrusif au début c'est assez bizarre
[Musique]
faye
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de start up
de produits innovants et de produits
destinés aux personnes sourdes et
malentendantes parce que si vous me
suivez
vous savez que j'aime bien paraître
start up alors pas tout le temps de
temps en temps j'ai souvent parlé de
start-up liés de l'écosystème français
la french tech business france
aujourd'hui je vous emmène en corée du
sud
je vais vous parler d'une start-up
coréenne très intéressante qui a créé un
tour de cou intéressant pour les
personnes sourdes et malentendantes
c'est un sujet je trouve vraiment très
très intéressant c'est pour ça que quand
on m'a proposé besoin de parler j'ai
tout de suite dit oui c'est ça ce tour
de cou là alors je vais vous expliquer à
quoi il sert si vous êtes sourds ou
malentendants est ce que vous connaissez
ce produit et vous me direz à la fin en
commentaire si c'est quelque chose que
vous pourriez avoir et si vous
connaissez une solution équivalente la
marque seiu force le produit ceni gouna
c'est un tour de cou l'idée de ce tour
de cou c'est que vous avez un micro de
chaque côté en fonction du son qui va
capter à droite ou à gauche
il va vibrer d'un côté ou l'autre d'une
certaine manière en fonction des bruits
qu'il va entendre c'est vraiment très
intéressant parce que ça permet de
capter la provenance dans son
typiquement une personne qui est sourde
ou malentendante va avoir à la sonnette
la porte et là bas quelqu'un sonne l
intérêt c'est que là effectivement vous
allez avoir une vibration ça vous dire
que depuis cet endroit là bas il y un
bruit qui arrive c'est en tout cas
vraiment bien vous dirigez en gros c'est
un système qui va vous alerter par
exemple vous avez fait tourner le
micro-ondes la cuisine et par là bas
vous l'avez fait tourner alors vous vous
bouclez votre chose le micro-ondes sol
ping et lui
vous dire à part la baille un bruit vous
savez forcément vous avez des micro
ondes ça vous indique donc que vous
pouvez les récupérer c'est vachement
intéressant alors il ya plein de
fonctionnalités
c'est un petit tour de cou qui est très
malin très intelligent je vous montre un
petit peu d'un point de vue purement
matériel comment ça marche ça se
présente donc comme ça vous le posez
directement autour de votre cou là vous
avez une partie qui est flexible vous
avez donc sur le côté une petite lettre
qui à vous aider pour connaître le
niveau de batterie pour le synchroniser
pour pas mal de choses de ce côté là
vous avez le bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre prélassent sur les boutons
pour adapter la sensibilité est ce que
vous voulez avec le bouton + qui
réagissent uniquement bruit qui vont
être très imposant donc celle des bruits
beaucoup moins fort il va pas vibrer
finesse que si vous baissez la
sensibilité je voulais diminué il va
réagir à des tout petits bruits ce n'est
pas très intéressant ici vous le
recharger en micro usb et si vous allez
régler l'intensité de la vibration est
ce que vous voulez qu'ils vibrent fort
moins fort ça va déjà dépendre de la
sensibilité personnelle du porteur du
tour de cou ça va dépendre de vos habits
si vous avez des amis qui sont un peu
plus épais je pense notamment en hiver
ou alors si vous êtes en tee shirt que
vous l'avez carrément directement sur la
peau vous n'avez pas vouloir les mêmes
sensations donc ça vous n'allez régler
directement ici là vous avez un mode
pause par exemple s'il ya beaucoup de
bruits extérieurs voulais juste mettre
la pause pendant un temps vous pouvez
vous laisse à pied pendant une seconde
il va se mettre en pause comme ça vous
êtes tranquilles néanmoins il n'est pas
éteint vous avez plus ensuite qu'à le
réactiver vous rappeler pendant deux
secondes il se réactive et reprend son
activité
il se positionne forcément hyper
facilement vous ouvrez vous le mettez
vous lâcher il se pose juste là alors
dans l'idée moi je trouve pas ça trop
intrusif au début c'est assez bizarre de
la côte et comme j'en ai pas le besoin
c'est vrai que bon ça vous rajoute un
truc vous dites c'est un peu bizarre
et au final je suis allé me balader dans
la rue j'ai fait différent et c'est vous
sentez plus et c'est vrai qu'à force
alors comme je vous dis une fois de plus
je
je ne suis ni son ni malentendants donc
je ne vais pas avoir les besoins je n'ai
pas à le ressentir et je ne t'ai pas
sentir tout de suite un sensation de 10
ans à génial c'est ça permet vraiment de
capter des provenances de son j'ai pas
besoin
néanmoins au bout d'un moment quand il a
fini par porter on s'y habitue et les
vibrations vous gêne pas c'est vrai que
vous le posez pour la première fois sur
vous vous avez ce truc qui va vibrer pas
constamment mais dès que vous avez un
bruit va vibrer peut paraître un peu
bizarre mais on s'y habitue très
rapidement ensuite vous avez une
application que vous pouvez retrouver
bien évidemment sur ios mais également
sur android alors sur ios oui mais pas
tout de suite il va arriver sur un os à
10 6 avril 2019 dont qui ne saurait
tarder alors à la caisse sur la vidéo
par contre sur android vous pouvez la
voir sur quasiment toutes les versions
d'android franchement là dessus vous
êtes tranquille l'app est juste là nous
gouna vous avez donc votre niveau de
charge tragique 87% de batterie il ne
cherche pas très vite faire de toute
façon en termes de techno s'est pas
complètement ouf on a un micro de chaque
côté on a des petites led
on va avoir des vibreurs donc bon c'est
pas hallucinant et communique en
bluetooth à ses très rapidement alors
sur la pluie c'est très intéressant vous
avez toute une partie alarme c'est à
dire que vous allez pouvoir régler une
allant par exemple pour vous réveiller
le matin vous dormez avec votre tour de
vous pour vous connaissez le système
veux me réveiller tel jour de la semaine
vous mettez votre réveil matinal vous
calibrer la durée de la vibration ou
recalibrées l'intensité vous lui mettez
un petit nom réveil matinal après là
c'est ce que vous voulez autre point
intéressant lorsque quelqu'un vous vous
appelez sur votre téléphone vous allez
pouvoir régler à l'intensité la
vibration et le nombre de vibrations
également vous pouvez également régler
si vous voulez de la vibration continue
ou une vibration mode alternatif est
exactement la même chose pour les sms
de ce point de vue là ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça vous permet
d'identifier le type de message ou le
type d'appels de notification vous allez
recevoir ça va pas vibrer de la même
manière et autre point qui est
intéressant vous allez pouvoir créer des
alertes pour la prise de médicaments moi
par exemple je me suis créé une alerte
reprendre mais antihistaminiques oui là
forcément ça y est avec les beaux jours
qui commence à arriver les allergies
sont de retour jeudi par exemple que je
prends de monk est un as à 3 heures 11
alors j'ai mis 3 euros je mettrai plus
le soir à mon avis j'ai pu te me dire
allez le soir à 9 heures mais paf je me
provoque estaing je rêve tous les
paramètres là je sauvegarde je retrouve
là et je peux me crée autant dallaire
que je veux vous voulez le mettre pour
des médicaments mais vous pouvez mettre
d'autres choses en gros vous vous créez
des rappels dont vous pouvez le
paramétrer pour tout ce que vous voulez
donc ça aussi c'est super intéressant et
il ya plein de gars
usage vous avez des animaux à la maison
il aboie vous voulez savoir où ils sont
où est-ce qu'ils aboient dans tous vos
déplacements même à l'extérieur vous
voulez traversée quelqu'un klaxons vous
captez vraiment la promotion du soffin
c'est vraiment intéressant
en gros c'est d'apercevoir les dangers à
connaître la provenance d'un son à
pouvoir identifier un appel un sms si
quelqu'un sonne à votre porte si micron
déterminé n'importe quel bruit et vous
pouvez vraiment connaître la position ça
vous sert de réveil enfin c'est vraiment
hyper polyvalent il ya plein de cas des
usages que je suis sûr que je ne suis
même pas capable de soupçonner ça nous
titille en train de se développer
vous pouvez commander en france si vous
voulez alors en termes de coût je vous
dire j'ai noté là il était à 298 $ sur
le site d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je
vous ai mis le lien mal dans la
description si vous voulez en savoir
plus voir plus d'informations vous
pouvez le trouver à 278 $ pour le moment
par contre y aussi des frais de
livraison pour l'instant ils sont 1 77 $
que vous faire livrer en france
ça vient de corée forcément il a un goût
de trajet à faire mais pour le service
rendu
je pense que c'est vraiment intéressant
il existe dans plusieurs couleurs blanc
et or noir gris et je trouve que c'est
un produit qui est super intéressant
c'est une vidéo que je fais avec mes
potes du café du geek vous pouvez
retrouver leur article complet je vous
ai mis également le lien dans la
description comme ça vous aurez plein
d'informations complémentaires et
franchement c'est cool voilà pour ce
produit
le new gounass écrit au ccri là devant
le new moon à la société seiu firth ça
nous vient tout droit de corée
c'est vraiment une solution qui est
intéressante dites moi vous en
commentaire ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes une personne
malentendante sourds d'ailleurs vous
noterez que la transcription sur cette
vidéo et dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est ce que cette solution vous l'a
trouvée intéressante
est-ce que vous pensez que ça apporte
vraiment c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée
pour les personnes sourdes et
malentendantes je trouve le concept très
intéressant c'est compliqué pour moi de
vous
dire parce que je ne suis pas confrontés
à cette problématique là donc c'est très
compliqué de pouvoir vous donner leur
tour exact mais en tout cas je trouve
que c'est vraiment un outil intéressant
et je me pose une question
je compte sur vous pour m'aider il
répond en tout cas c'est est ce que vous
connaissez les solutions alternatives
des solutions similaires qui existent
sur le marché
et est ce que celle-ci vous semblerez si
c'est le cas en tout cas plus
intéressante oui je vous invite à
marquer tout ça en bas en commentaire
vidéo un peu à part mais ça valait le
coup je vous donne donc rendez vous dès
demain on sera au mwc à barcelone on va
aller découvrir toutes les nouveautés de
l'univers de la téléphonie mobile
smartphone et bien plus encore vous
allez voir ça va être hyper cool et vous
réserve plein de belles surprises nous
embrassades mains de change